my first guess can be seen in the
upcoming film eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind please give a big welcome
home to ontario's own
jim gary
hello
i love this city
[Applause]
but what really keeps me coming back to
p.o
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a place to stand and a place to
go
they call this land ontario
place to stand the place to grow ontario
come on conan try the music of my
native land all right
there's a place to stand and elevates to
roar
they call this land ontario
a place you stand up please
[Music]
[Applause]
very
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do that again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
very nice oh thanks
conan o'brien oh no it's jim carrey
canada
oh my god yeah i gotta
[Laughter]
no i can't use that again stop that it's
a beaver
where are my canadians on your show yeah
that's what they've been chewing on the
desk all week
next thing you know the river's damned
up uh you know i want to first of all
we got to thank you uh for for coming up
here to toronto this is a great thing
you owe me a lot
yes i do no but no and you too as well
and isn't this a wonderful thing for
everybody
to be up here it's truly
because it's been a hard hard year for
you guys i know there's been the
the sars thing and there's been you know
the the blackouts and uh
pestilence whatever else is going on up
here but uh i got some good news
you got good news yeah i saved a ton
good timing good timing on the joke
there yeah let's go back yeah so uh
but i got some good news you got some
good news yeah i spent i saved a lot of
money
on my car insurance switching to geico
it's better than second time it's better
it was better yeah
that's amazing the way in comedy
completely screws up
yeah it creates another opportunity an
expectation
that's right very nice now uh
your head is sweating a lot right now
yeah
here
[Laughter]
[Music]
here we go now you you you're still the
you know i thought you were the you
always seem like a down to earth guy
same old guy that
that left this town and went out to earn
your fame unfortunately you're filthy
rich though yeah you have
and you've got normally so yeah
a lot of money
but you've also uh you've got a little
you showed up with an entourage which i
found a little disappointing no it's not
like me but when i come back to canada
there's a lot of people i don't get to
see
and so i brought a few people you know
just they just hang out with me i guess
they
they're my canadian posse this is your
canadian possibility can i introduce
some of them yeah sure
and let's see who they are uh that's the
amazing amazing crescent
amazing crescent right there good to see
you
how are you oh miss uh that's
peter puck of course who taught me
everything about hockey right right uh
[Applause]
cleansing things
there's some good will with the french
people there you go
now let me ask you something jim you
canadians you have kind of a wild sense
of humor can you tell us anything about
the canadian sense of humor well
while you towel off what happens
usually the follicles keep it in yeah ah
yeah we have a weird sense of humor up
here kind of thing
ours was very rough you know with each
other when we were when i was growing up
i had a
you know because very very strange
cutting sense of humor but we always had
a saving grace
we had a thing i don't know if this is
true of every canadian but we had a
thing called
the kidding face the kidding face kitty
face lets your friend know that you
don't really mean what you're saying and
then he
does the kidding face back to you
letting you know that um
that he's understands that you're
kidding can i see the kidding face what
would be like
you're an idiot
[Laughter]
that's very nice yeah i don't know if
that's a distinctly canadian thing but
right
right seems to me it is right right try
it go ahead uh
you're a stupid guy
see and everybody's friends you can say
whatever you want that's great
it's amazing yeah yeah you're you're a
you're you're you're
dumb in every way and i hate your hair
hey let me try one yeah you look stupid
bald
[Applause]
that's really funny man well i did the
fans oh that's really funny well i
you said to the face no it's just the
one thing that i didn't really want you
to touch on and you did
no it's fine i mean i guess that's how
you get your kicks
out here this illusion of superiority
that you have i swear to god i'm sorry
it's all funny puppet master you know
running everybody's lives coming into
another country oh i own the place
big deal you're no big deal up here
mister you can't be a star up here
you're a normal person like everybody
else
and guess what else no one likes you
conan
no one likes you and you're gonna die
alone
control of your ass i become liquid up
here liquid
i'm telling you now uh become one with
the elements you have
we got to start putting sound effects on
that now i understand this may be
sensitive subject up here
uh i understand jim that you're you've
been trying very hard
to get uh to get u.s citizenship yeah uh
that's
i know i understand i know please hear
them
hear the man out i think it's only said
i know it's never a popular thing and
it's a very kind of a sticking
subject but you know i want to vote and
you know my child goes to school there
and
right right there's a lot of reasons
well we have a little surprise for you i
know you've been trying to do this for a
long time yeah
jim your u.s citizenship has come
through we have guy secunder from the
u.s department of immigration
naturalization here with your official
documents
all you have to do is sign a piece of
paper and you are a u.s citizen that's
all you have to do
you get your passport you sign that
they'll give you a passport
here you go and now you get your
passport uh there you go there's your us
passport right there wow this is just
fantastic it truly is a real this is a
real no really it's a dream come true
for me
i just have one question for you mr
segundo why would i want to become a us
citizen when i'm from the greatest
country in the world
you know what i think to your passport
huh you know what i think of your
password
it tastes like manifest
it get destiny of here
keep going good man it's just a bit
right
okay you have the real one no great
thank you so
come on back out here again
boy you know it was great it was uh
terrific
uh having you uh i know you're very busy
you made the time to come here to do the
show and
you weren't busy at all you didn't have
anything to do
you pretty much your whole schedule was
open wasn't it
i know the entire fall lineup man
it was great of you to come i just i
just wish that there was a nice way to
get out of this segment to end it on a
high note
well there's one way there's one way
there's a place to stand
ontario a place to
[Applause]
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you